es ist dann letztlich der nächste wahl
ich habe keinen uns gestellt waren
ich habe keine balance des autos geht ab
von herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe euch jetzt ruht
uns auf wir haben bei der heim elf am
abend genau jetzt mal wenn man auf und
geht die geschäftsführung an
das hat sich jetzt schon jetzt dreimal
so auf jeden fall sind wir gerade noch
an bord produzieren ich bin nämlich ab
morgen früh weg eine woche kreisklasse
verabreden also ich mache mit bei dieser
serie auf youtube die einen von euch
werden scannen die anderen auch nicht
ich bin mal gespannt wie es wird auf
jeden fall machen wir heute mal was ganz
neues ich lese auch sehr oft unter den
videos von jo alex macht doch auch mal
was von einem anderen shop wir haben so
viele shops die es gibt also soll china
schrott jugend wo war ali express und so
weiter als ich das schon so viele
nachrichten zu bekommen und ich habe vor
zwei wochen mir gedacht komm du hast
bayerisch 3 platz gemacht in denen du
kostenlose sachen getestet also so
billig produkte die man für sehr wenig
geld bekommt man musste nur den versand
bezahlen und bei der plattform nun ist
es so da gibt es auf viele produkte die
ungefähr ein bis zwei euro kosten und da
muss man nichts im versand bis sein also
von der wertigkeit sind die ungefähr
beide gleich deswegen machen wir heute
weiter mit 10 1 euro produkten von juden
und ich bin mal gespannt was da
angekommen ist
leute die haben sogar eine eigene
verpackung da müssen wir nicht mehr
nachdenken also unglaublich 1 amano
ja also das ist doch sieht doch geil aus
oder
natürlich ist das jetzt nicht so
umweltfreundlich weiß zu mir leid aber
es geht immer um den inhalten davon
unsere plastik denn jetzt kam raus und
zeichnet oder oder halt wieder als
mülltüten verwenden uns genau ich muss
sagen hier habe ich schon einige sachen
drin ich glaube insgesamt sechs
verschieden
12 hab mir jetzt immer 12
das ist schon mal 6 7 8 9 10
also die passen irgendwie immer mehrere
produkte in einen umschlag nach sind
dann muss man nicht alles einzeln
verschicken 11 12 achso hier ist auch
noch was drin
13 4 ist denn 15 sind also ich habe
irgendwie das gefühl da ist alles
kompletter schrott ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern als ich da saß und
gestellt habe okay dass hier kostet
einen euro nur mit mal gucken was
angekommen dass sie kostet 1 euro und
mein erster eindruck ist auf jeden fall
dass die kostenlosen produkte von milch
besser waren als diese hier oder
interessanter sagen wir mal so ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich kann mich auch
nicht mehr grösser erinnern was ich da
bestellt habe deswegen hatten wir
einfach mal drauf aus los also packen
wir einfach mal drauf drauflos aus
drauflos oder auch immer also wir fangen
jetzt alle sagen immer so und hier
werden dann natürlich auch immer die
sachen wie sie mir bei jungen angezeigt
wurden eingeblendet was ist das sicher
ich habe keine ahnung und deswegen
welche clips ticker ja irgendwie sowas
nie weiß was es ist
das sind so reflektor fürs fahrrad also
die doberan zwar dran war auch nicht die
bestellt habe ich dachte mir kommen die
macht einfach mal in einen autoreifen
dass man machen da ich kurz nur
interessantes produkt ich leg mal zur
seite hätte das gedacht wir testen das
war eben hier im auto vor allem das wohl
aussieht wenn es fährt als sie sind ja
eigentlich fürs fahrrad gemacht zumal
die qualität auf das sich lohnt sollte
eigentlich ganz entspannt hier dran
fassen
es gibt so viele moslems in köln dann
setze ich meine allerdings ein bisschen
ab und ich mache drei dran
sieht doch zu heftig aus oder
super jetzt lässt sich im dunkeln noch
mehr gesehen
einfach mal dran lassen heute weiß ich
noch ganz schnell sagen wollte und zwar
in zwei freunde von mir der christ und
der mag die kennt ihr vielleicht auch
die haben am 14
also schon in wenigen tagen um 14 uhr in
köln auf der hohe straße galeria kaufhof
ein zuschauer treffen zusammen mit
beyblade checkt erstmal ob da könnt ihr
sehr gerne vorbei gehen die freuen sich
auf jeden fall über euch wenn grüße an
euch weiter auch und kann leider nicht
vor ort sein
vielleicht doch aber ich glaube nicht
weil ich nicht in köln bin aber es wird
meist und wir machen jetzt weiter mit
einem video
genauso wie diese sachen sieht man dann
im nächsten partnern okay manchmal
weiter ich lasse einfach mal den laptop
hier auch weil das ist wichtig sonst
kann ich gleich überhaupt nicht
orientieren
jetzt bisschen mehr drin mal schauen
ohne spaß
ich würde das habe ich nicht gestellt
ich habe doch keinen auf dem tisch
bestellen
er war ohne spaß jetzt das habe ich
wirklich nicht bestellt bekommt es rein
also ohne spaß ich habe das nicht
bestellt was ist das denn
und dann nimmst du leute die verkaufen
so was auf der kirmes ein kleine kinder
für zehn euro einbringen wo helium prinz
wer möchte dass haben einmal daumen nach
oben
dann zeige ich euch das nach hause das
sind schon wieder luft weil und ich
haben keine luftballons gestellt war
stiegen die ja da nicht mehr daran
[Musik]
junge alte regale gleich sauber macht
ich bin ich hab was du bist jetzt weiß
wer deswegen ist es auch eigentlich so
leiste produkte auch wenn ich die
wirklich nicht bestellt haben juni wir
machen mal weiter
wahrscheinlich sind jetzt wieder bei uns
drin sind nicht was haben wir denn hier
ich weiß was ist es das müssen wir beim
nächsten part machen weil das ist ein
oranges schneider
damit scheint es so orange auf aber ich
habe keinen organisieren das ist wird
leute kommt im nächsten part das testen
wir das mal aus was funktioniert ich
mache weiter nächste produkt ich weiß
schon was ist wenn ich habs gerade
gesehen übrigens leute wenn ihr diese
videos feiert in denen ich halt
irgendwelche sachen bestellen
von solchen jobs in zukunft wird es auch
viel mit der ebwo war geben das ist wohl
so ein neues ding was total im hype ist
da habe ich ein paar sachen bestellt zum
beispiel im playstation controller und
handy und so weiter dann lassen nach
oben da ist super wichtig weil es macht
sehr viel spaß und ich möchte auf jeden
fall das main kanal sich so ein bisschen
auch in diese richtung verändert habe
ich ja am anfang des jahres auch schon
mal so ein bisschen gesagt und blogger
aktivieren nicht vergessen ganz klar wir
haben hier also die werden die auf jeden
fall damit dass man damit so diese
trugen vor den fenstern sauber machen
kann aber auch seine tastatur ich bleibe
euch diese fotos hier allemal ein was
das hier ist habe ich bis jetzt auch
noch nicht so ganz verstanden genau also
dass hier sind ja diese borsten und dann
kann man das hier noch raus fahren
sozusagen
ja ja ja so und hier ist jetzt eine
schaufel um so ein bisschen unglücklich
oder absolut absolut unnötig naja das
mal kurz hier beim beim fenster ein mal
gucken ob es funktioniert also damit
wird die reinen produktfotos geworben
dass man hier ganz entspannt das fenster
sauber machen kann
auf jeden fall ein ice bei kummer ist
ein bisschen staub mit gekommen ja aber
toll eine dritte das war dann das erste
punkt alles machen was ich absolut nicht
weiterempfehlen kann man muss ja ganz
klar sagen die gesunde sachen die sind
einfach so wie ein blatt papier
das ist ein witziges bringen darf ich
das war nicht echt witzig und zwar im
klebt man das an die toilette
downloading krone wie dem ein mann
haushalt auch der getötete ich habe auch
gedacht so alter ist das ungünstig kommt
leute dann mal ab in unserer led wand
öffnet diese leuchten die talente
[Musik]
also ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht super gefällt mir cooler
ferner sticker für einen kleinen witz
ist man ja immer zu haben oder die
unsere gäste die jetzt aufs klo gehen
die lachen sich dort weg in die
schmunzelnde oder philips also unser bad
ist auf jeden fall voller überraschungen
neuerdings so ein paar sachen haben wir
noch für den heutigen tag macht normal
weiter sie ist dann letztlich der
nächste bond ich habe keine wahl
gestellt waren
ich habe keine balance bestätigte nur
kurz was ist im ballon ist vielleicht
nein ich habe keine balance war das also
kann ich nicht von anfang an leute das
tut mir persönlich auch total leid aber
was willst du machen sowas schauen wir
haben hier in schrift den habe ich
bestellt da bin ich mir sicher
mit diesen dingen bist du in der schule
aber der coolste folgen der grundschule
hast du eine ahnung was das hier ist ja
denke damit kannst du sowohl sich
verschreiben weißt du das wirklich
stimmt ja auch kenne und gefeiert haben
nie eingenommen haben warum kommen warum
[Musik]
bin ich mal weiter warten
also ich von den witz es ganz lustig
bevor ich weiter für eine entschuldigung
juri entschuldigung es tut mir leid es
tut mir leid ist der krasseste du bist
der kassel huskies treten und das okay
das ist jetzt das produkt was ich für
diesen park ist als letztes eingeplant
habe das ist ein geiles legales produkt
habe ich richtig gefeiert worden ich
kann mir wirklich vorstellen dass das
leute bestellen und zwar ist das für
leute die gerne ein tattoo haben wollen
aber es sich nicht machen dürfen oder
ist sich nicht machen wollen das ist
praktisch schon überzieht dazu für die
ganz harten meiste und das ziel jetzt
mal ich ziehe mein t shirt an
bislang weiß ich muss sagen ich finde es
ganz schlecht oder
so sieht doch ganz klar dass sich als
achter zum feiern geben möchte dann sage
ich mir ich hab natur und so fällt dir
nun noch kommt dass bestimmte leute ich
würde sagen ich hoffe ja spaß beim
zuschauen treibt weitere idee in die
kommentare
abonniert den kanal geben doch nach oben
abonniert die glocke die activity
vehicle check von ist ab 30 alex wie wir
sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr wieder da
gibt's neues video aus rein und ich muss
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen aufräumen
[Musik]